[Music]
demand for a covet vaccine in this
country has plummeted as most americans
have received their full set of doses or
refused to get vaccinated at all but
that's not the case in other parts of
the world including just over the u.s
border in mexico one doctor in laredo
texas has been spearheading an effort to
distribute donated vaccines to people in
nearby nuevo laredo mexico especially
for children who are not yet eligible in
that country manuel jorge has got a look
at how it's done
6 30 you got in line it's already almost
11.
not far from the u.s border this is the
line for a covet vaccine hundreds of men
women and children in nuevo mexico wait
hours for a chance to get the shot this
line is here almost every day
every day every day every day dr victor
trevino works on the other side in
laredo texas but is leading a
bi-national effort to distribute donated
vaccines here and the reason for that is
because we're one community
and water affects us affects them and
vice versa so where both communities are
150 miles away from
major cities so we have to tend to our
needs locally so the team with the
approval of u.s customs and border
protection devised a way to bring people
to a secure spot along the port of entry
there are a few reasons they bus people
to the point of entry to distribute the
vaccines one is they don't want to
export vaccines that were paid for by
u.s tax dollars but these doses were
just days away from expiring they were
donated by doctors on the u.s side who
said there are no takers there and there
are plenty of takers here especially
parents with children under five who are
not yet eligible for the vaccine here
josefina guerra is here with her two
grandchildren and they're going for
their second shot
once parked dr trevino joins other
doctors and nurses on the bus where the
shots and crying begin
followed by gratitude from adults who
got the shot too like josefina you have
hypertension and diabetes
so this is very important
on the way back some of the kids show up
on your arm
you didn't cry no you're raste
you're strong
oh you play baseball that's why you're
so strong
nuevo laredo's mayor carmen lilia
canturosa says the children's
vaccinations have given her city a
milestone
six months to four years old
five years uh-huh 12
the first annual in the mexico city in
all of it in all of mexico
the bi-national program after more than
a year has vaccinated 250 000 people and
counting well people are very grateful
and it's you have a smile on your face
doing it i like it
it's very satisfying we do it because
that's a need we have the need and we
step up to the plate uniting two
countries for a common cause
there you go
for cbs saturday morning manuel
pojorquez mexico
you know we've said since the beginning
this is a global pandemic it's a global
problem and to see help
happening across borders obviously such
a huge difference they say two countries
working together there you go it's one
community whether or not what side of
the border you're on yeah and those
lines reminded me of early on when we
were all trying to get vaccines here as
well or many we all remember that